[Music]
robert dubois
he's in prison for putting superman in
the icu with a kryptonite bullet i'm not
joining your suicide squad
we'll see my court date is coming up
and miss waller said maybe you could
help me out you're threatening my door
out everyone stand down
stand down
[Music]
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this mission went more important than
you could possibly imagine
are you in or out good
let's meet your team yes okay i'm not
okay each member has chosen for his or
her own completely unique set of
abilities
[Music]
hey guys sorry i'm late let's go number
two good to know
is this thing a dog a dog what kind of
dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound
oh my god is it a werewolf y'all next
time you need this
yo let me out yeah he's not a werewolf
okay he's a weasel
he's harmless i mean he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but
you know
your mission is to destroy every trace
of something known
only as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
think there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing i'm a superhero
i'm going to get you out of here alone
[Music]
stay off the calm